stan when you were a child would you
color within the lines
i never called the wooden lines i was uh
the
kind of oddball kid i uh i enjoyed old
movies
from a very young age my parents were
both
very young when they had us my sister
and i i think my mother was 22
and so because of that when i got to be
of an age where she could drop me
somewhere on a weekend
she would do that so she could have some
time to herself because she was still in
her 20s
and freaking with my grandparents and
when it wasn't it was some place
so maybe it was an arts and crafts thing
at the museum and then one weekend it
was the lido theater on pico
and they were showing a wc fields double
feature you can't cheat an honest man
and never give a sucker and even break
and i was alone with my popcorn for four
hours
and this black and white majesty was
happening on the screen
and if a kid at nine years old could
have an epiphany i had one
and from that point on i watched black
and white movies whenever i could and
usually was in the middle of the night
unbeknownst to my parents i would sneak
downstairs i would turn on channel 11 or
channel 13 and in between
used car commercials i would watch night
at the opera day at the races and then i
learned about laurel and hardy and so
then i moved on to them and then i moved
on to humphrey bogart and spencer tracy
and so by the time i finished
middle school and high school i had a
journal where i would had kept notes of
all these black and white movies i had
seen
and in my junior year of high school i
trick-or-treated at groucho marx's house
and met groucho and then groucho invited
me
and six friends to come back and we
spent the day with him
which was glorious so no i definitely
did not
color inside the lines did he pass out
good candy by the way
well so the four of us went as as the
marx brothers and i went as groucho
and uh we had memorized bits from their
movies and what happened was we were on
our way to
the high school halloween party and
uh one of the dads said uh
you know i know where groucho is why
don't we stop you'll tell your friends
that you
trick-or-treat at grouch's house when
you get to the party and we went okay
and never figuring we'd ever see him and
so they drove all the way up to the top
of truesdale and beverly hills and
we rang the bell and wait wait wait and
then all of a sudden we hear yes and we
go
trick or treat by the way houses up
there were you know miles apart so
nobody was trick-or-treating ever
so that's these big giant white doors
open and it was like valhalla because it
was an
all-white interior very modern and the
front of the house went to all the way
to the back of the house and the back of
the house was a white wall
with the sketch of groucho from an even
groucho so there was no doubt where you
were
and so she goes oh lord she sees us
oh lord and she goes i gotta go get
something for you to have so she
departs so now the four of us are
standing in this little glow of the
light in
in the portico and we're waiting for her
to come back and
groucho's partner girlfriend whatever
aaron fleming crossed from one side of
the house to the other looked down
and saw us this community of marx
brothers
and she says groucho you got to come see
this
and of course he came from the last room
in the house
and he starts coming towards us and it
wasn't until he got about halfway down
the hall it dawned on me that
i was him like we had been the marx
brothers as a unit but
as he got to me i realized i was groucho
and i look around and my friends have
bailed they are too scared they're off
in the shadows now so now i'm standing
right
in this glow and he's coming at me and i
i can literally see my heart beating out
of my white shirt
and i'm holding my little plastic cigar
and my hand is shaking
and he finally gets to the door and his
beret and his cardigan sweater
and he looks at me and he's waiting for
me to say something
and in my very best 15 year old groucho
i say
well looks like i'm looking in the
mirror and groucho returned
by saying no you're much uglier and i
could die right then because i had been
insulted by groucho marx
so that's pretty much how it went and
then my friends returned and the
my friend john who played harpo and i
did
two scenes from coconuts and day at the
races he was delighted and
and then went on his way and then merv
griffin
interviewed him about six months later
and he told the story on the merv
griffin show which made us of course
so giggly happy and then we had the we
called and said thank you and he said
would you like to come up to the house
and spend some time and so we did and
uh that's the photo and that's the
autograph and yeah
wow yeah and it was just it was just
sort of almost on a dare
that you were going it was all it was
never planned it was all
magical it was you know in hilariously
in the 1970s the city of beverly hills
had a private phone book that was only
delivered to people that lived there
and every resident of beverly hills was
in the book
you could unlist your phone number but
you could not unlist your address
that's how the star maps were made and
and of course
horrible things started to happen and
that was the end of that but at the time
we just opened the book and flipped to
groucho marx and it said where he was
living so we knew exactly where to go
thinking back to that experience and how
sort of this dare this sort yeah i mean
it wasn't planned
how much does that shape your career as
a producer
just taking risks like that or oh
there's i don't know that that shaped my
career any other more than
i felt like there was kismet that had
happened and that
how could i not pursue a career
having had this incredible moment with
groucho marx and
i mean i thought was there was something
that had happened magically that i had
to pursue
and i look i entered college as a
pre-med
flunked out of organic chemistry on my
first semester of my first year and
that was the end of that and so by the
end of my
four years i on a lark i applied to the
american film institute and got in
and then started in the mail room so my
career has always sort of been shaped by
not necessarily the path that anyone
else expected me to take
um you know i come out of afi thinking
i'm going to be a
producer of film instantly
and then i end up not being able to get
a job for six months and starting in the
mail room and the mailroom was for a
television company
and that just sent my trajectory of my
career towards television and so
i'm eventually producing television
movies became
what was right for me but it wasn't a
choice i didn't i
i have so far outlived my dreams that
little kid who was nine years old who
was sneaking downstairs to watch
laurel hardy imagined himself in the
movie business but
doing something you know getting to be
on a set or being a sound man or a
cameraman but
the idea that i would be a producer and
have my own company and produce my own
movies and travel all over the world to
make movies and win an emmy and golden
globe all but none of that was ever in
the
in my imagination i've gone far past
what i ever imagined would happen for me
and that's my dad standing in the
background who drove us
and that's groucho that's unbelievable
and he had just won the honorary oscar
like two months before
wow that's so cool i was so uh we asked
him
and because the five of us really knew
the marks brothers so well
we asked him like we margaret dumont was
always his foil
and we asked him i don't know if you
know what that is but margaret dumont
was in all of his movies and was sort of
the straight woman
oh she was like the mrs rittenhouse she
was always the woman who was in the
highfalutin job that they would poke fun
at sure
because most of their movies come
through darts at the
privileged class and so groucho was
always the
lead that would be approached by this
you know
woman of ayers and it was always played
by margaret dumont in every movie
and she goes back to when they were on
uh vaudeville so she was she was a foil
for them
early on and so of course i said why was
she
so good at keeping i don't know how she
kept a straight face
in that and with the chaos around her
and with being with the funniest people
on the planet
and he said well it was very simple she
didn't get it
she never thought we were funny and
and i'm sure that was true i'm sure she
never thought they were funny i mean
there's no way you could keep a straight
face with groucho marx you know
hold me closer hold me closer if i went
any closer i'd be behind you
you know how does she how does that line
happen and she's dead
pan serious right well it's similar with
robin william
morgan mindy so i don't know how you
would yeah i wouldn't be able to yes
but having made the morgan mini movie uh
i did my research on that she
they the people on that set broke every
time oh they did oh yeah they would okay
reset and start again
yeah but margaret dumont never she never
did never nothing
now she was she had to be that good
because she came from theater
so there was no take two now in the
movies there were but he she had
become their foil they did this amazing
thing when they did
coconuts which is their first movie
which were going on a big tangent but
when they did their first movie
they took that screenplay and they went
and acted it out all over the country in
venues all over the
country in fact that's the crew in
denver
wow that's the crew photo from when they
were performing
the coconuts movie lime out it wasn't a
movie yet it was they had never made a
movie
they did it live in a 35 cities and
every and the screenwriters were in the
audience and so if the jokes didn't work
they rewrote it for the next city and if
those jokes didn't work they would so by
the time they got to make the movie for
mgm
the jokes were all killer jokes because
they had performed them
it's like a stand-up getting ready to do
his hbo special well they're well
they'll do you know chris
rock will do it 150 times so that every
joke
works that's what they did now no
obviously nobody does that for a comedy
movie now
but that's why the coconuts has not was
not one bit one after another that
doesn't work
and vaudeville was from what how long to
well the teens and twenties
okay it stopped during the process yeah
i mean
when people didn't have the kind of
money but also that when the talkies
became big then
vaudeville ceased to have as much
importance as
you know as the talkie movies kind of
replaced vaudeville
sure okay when you're producing is it
important for you to follow the rules
or forge another path i think when
you're a producer you have to do both
um you have the business side and the
creative side that you have to find
a happy medium so you have to follow the
rules in terms of
somebody's giving you money whether it's
a network or studio and they have an
expectation of what you're going to give
them
and so that's following some rules you
have a budget
you have a schedule you have to finish
in this amount of days you have
especially in the television business
where we don't have the luxury of going
over
you have to make sure that you spend the
amount of money they give you and no
more
and preferably no less you want to put
as much money on the screen as possible
so those are rules you got to follow
on the other hand as a producer i want
to find the very best people possible
in every position from acting to
directing to craft service to hair and
makeup
and then i want to create an environment
so they can do their best work and that
may include coloring outside the lines
that may include some improv from them
or that may include the hair and makeup
people coming you know
i know that the script calls for her to
have her hair up in the scene but
i'll tell you it doesn't feel right she
doesn't feel like that's what
she wants and i don't feel like that's
what she should have so
okay let's do it the other way so you
those rules you break
um i just directed macy gray in a movie
and she uh
came to me after day one and said this
hair and this makeup and this wardrobe
is all wrong for this character
i know you never reshoot in television
movies
but if there's any way i can redo my
stuff from day one i would like to redo
it and
she came to the set the next day in a
totally different wardrobe totally
different hair totally different makeup
and she was
right she was dead on right she we had
gotten it wrong
and we re-shot day one later in the
schedule but we did we re-shot day one
because she was right she was
what we had planned from the script was
not
as good as what she had brought to the
table um she understood that character
better than we did
and uh so i think that's what you have
to be open to that and that's definitely
breaking the rules i think those rules
are are meant to be broken i think you
have to be open
to the creative juices coming from
anywhere it's a really a team effort it
takes a village to make a movie i mean
you know john ford said the best movies
have happy accidents and i think that's
true
i think you have to be open to you know
the famous shot in the searchers where
the cloud cover comes over they have
that giant vista and the cloud comes
over and
the dp was saying we're losing the light
and john ford said didn't don't cut
because the it was a metaphor for what
was coming in the movie and he saw it
and he understood that that cloud cover
he would never be able to get ever and
he said
that was the happy accident and made
searchers so powerful and he
you know you have to be open to that
who got you into producing i got into
producing because
it's always i was a producing fellow at
the american film institute so it was
always my intention to produce i had uh
been in college head of all student
programs so i had produced concerts and
lectures and
dances and so there's some theater and
so i had producing
kind of in my bones and i had read up on
famous producers like selznick and rob
walsh and
i kind of admired what they did of
course they were in the studio system
which i knew i was never going to have
the luxury of being
in but i really wanted to be sort of
that person on top that got to do
everything but did nothing
you know all that had gotten my arms
around all of it but
and had creative say but on the other
hand you know wasn't responsible for any
of their specific jobs
um but then you know mail room and then
i was a reader and then a development
executive and
eventually i learned a lot about
producing from working for peter guber
and john peters i think we think those
years those four years were
like you know getting a master's phd in
producing i watched how they packaged
films and
and then i learned how to line produce
basically
by making my first movie where i was on
the hook for deficit for cbs pair of
aces with willie nelson and chris
christopherson and
my children's college education and my
house was up against the
the the film finishing and finishing on
time and not going over budget
and so i took a crash course with the
line producer and he was
he was very good at sitting me down
going these are the things you have to
do these are things you shouldn't do and
by the time i did my second movie where
i was on the hook
um i kind of knew how to line produce so
now i was an executive producer line
producer so i could do both the creative
and i could do the
the financial the creative probably came
from
working for peter guber and john peters
and the line producing came from
you know trial by fire if you don't mind
me asking stan how did you
end up in a position where your house
and your children's college education
was online
so in so
in the 70s 80s and 90s when the
television movie business was at its
height when cbs nbc abc and then
eventually fox all had movie nights
i mean you don't remember about the time
there was a movie night on cbs nbc
aviation
all on sunday night so at nine o'clock
there was a movie on against each other
then
cbs had a tuesday night movie and nbc
had a monday night movie
all of those movies were made by
independent suppliers because the
studios didn't want to be in the
television movie business because it was
not financially beneficial to them and
the networks had not yet owned their own
product so the only people that were
making it
were independence and i found that
fascinating that you could be
both a studio and a producer at the same
time that you would own your negatives
that you would be on the hook for
making sure that the picture finished on
time and it would be your money going
into it you'd have to find you'd get
money from a network but then you'd have
to find the international money and
eventually we all use tax credits most
of us going to canada
when those came into fashion and that's
how you put the movie together so we
learned both how to
package creatively but also how to
package financially and then
all of us whether it was land hill or
or any of the famous television movie
producers
um from that era and we all were busy
we're all making three or four movies a
year
um primarily in canada but we all were
on the hook for deficit we all were
taking all the risk and then we could
own it you know nobody in the series
business was owning their their shows
those are all owned by studios and
obviously
very few in the independent feature
business so the only real business
during the 70s 80s and 90s where you
could own
a library where you could amass a
library and i have 42 titles in my
library
um could come in the television movie
business
there was actually an article that peter
guber wrote and i think was for like the
harvard review it's not like i'm reading
that all the time but i
just happened to see that in researching
for this um interview and it was about
how fidel castro
sort of finessed you you know what story
i'm referring to
okay yes and uh ocean quest yes i was a
production executive yeah
and and what i found interesting was he
talked about it's not just the story for
your movie
but it's also the story that you tell
other people that are either on your
crew
or having been denied by the film office
there
he was able to tell a story to fidel
castro have the cameras ready
maybe i'll let you finish i'm sorry well
that whoa
i i can tell the the the story of fidel
castro and ocean quest
from my side from the sea from the
from dockside where i was because i was
back in los angeles
so peter sold a six-hour mini-series
documentary series to brandon tardikov
may rest in peace
uh called ocean quest which basically
was take this
beautiful woman who was miss universe
john weatherly put her with america's
answers to jacques cousteau and take
them to the great dive spots all over
the world
and do it for a year and and then when
it was done
cut six episodes and so we had six one
hours that went
on consecutive sundays against murder
she wrote
and uh it was it was sort of a big nbc
event
and we went non-sweeps so
one of the things that peter wanted to
do and by the way he sold it because he
owned 110-foot pleasure
sailboat and he wanted to figure out a
way to ride off his boat so if the boat
was on the show then he could
use it as a tax write-off so and then he
handed it to me because i was his head
of television and said you go do it and
so
uh we were based out of al giddings who
was america's jacques stone had shot
like the deep and jaws and all the
underwater stuff
and so he had a big production facility
in
in berkeley in oakland and so that's
where we were based and i would fly up
and back during the week
and this was during the the post but
when we were in production
um i was just responsible for making
sure that
you know the network got what they
wanted and we had we had big outlines
and then i introduced the production
staff to the network the network to the
production staff and
and then if there was any dialogue that
had to happen and
so uh i get a phone call from the new
york based lawyers
for the production company that was
doing at center point productions and
they said uh
we want to see the production schedule
okay so i send them the production
schedule
and we're on episode three and
peter's boat with sean and al
the two stars and the crew are is
motoring towards cuba
because fidel castro is an avid diver
the deepest point on the atlantic
is near cuba there was this giant trench
that they wanted to send a
rove down and they also wanted to dive
near it with fidel fidel's gonna go in
the water with al
and sean and as we get
it's motoring down in towards
international waters i get a phone call
from new york
when is the shot with fidel castro in
cuba and i said well that's
like in three days peter's on the boat
now he said
turn him around i said what no i can't
turn around
i'm at 24 years old i go i can't turn
him around i don't know why i can't turn
bars
there's not even any phones like there's
no cell phones he's in a boat he goes
you have to
he says as soon as he hits cuban waters
the american coast guard is going to
seize his boat and arrest them all
because you have no permission from the
american government
to do something commercial there and we
had this embargo that was pretty fierce
and he said they will arrest him and
they will impound his boat
i went what he goes why didn't anybody
ask us about this i said well you've
seen the production schedule how was i
supposed to know that that was illegal
so he says find them so i find
i call somebody maria del rey they send
me well if they have a ship to shore
you can call somebody who will ship to
shore a message to them and then they
can ship to shore a message back to you
and so i got a ship to shore message i
said stop
they anchored where they were before
they entered fidel castro and i went to
my boss's office so that's the guy that
runs the whole production company and i
said
tom tannebaum legendary television
executive
uh son eric tannenbaum produced uh two
and a half man and
just a sort of uh the barrymores of tv
executives
and i say to tom we have a horrible
problem this is what's happening i've
got him to stop but what do we do now
and he said i don't know there's only
one person in all of hollywood who can
fix this
he says there's a lawyer one lawyer who
could fix problems like this named greg
bowser
greg bowser is this wyman bowser is this
legendary he represented universal
studios and
when he became universal studios he was
in his 70s already
this was you know i guess long since
gone and
he says sit down and he puts on the
speakerphone and he calls and he goes
he goes greg yeah what is it he goes
it's tom i have this big problem
he brings the problem to him bowser goes
all right stay by your phone
you're going to get a phone call in the
next half hour from al haig
al haig at the time was the secretary of
defense he goes
tom goes uh okay we wait wait wait sure
enough ring ring ring
mr tannenbaum yes al hague secretary
defense
we went yes he goes what's to happen he
tells him he goes okay normally
this would take a month to get through
the
the commerce department i will get this
done
in 24 hours tell him not to leave but in
24 hours i will get you the piece of
paper he needs
to get into cuba the waiver sure enough
24 hours later
he came and peter murdered his way to
meet with final castro so that's
i'm sure that was not in the harvard
review that's my side of the story
the one in the wow that is quite a story
and and the one that was in the hartford
review and i
i didn't read the full thing i skimmed
it i think he said that they positioned
the cameras
and ms weatherly in her swimsuit to just
show sort of this
they were ready to shoot and then he
presented his side of the story and and
that the film office had denied
and it seemed like it was because they
weren't really able to tell
their story of what they wanted to do it
was like this these forms
and so he just was talking about sort of
the four noble truths of storytelling
and how it can it doesn't just translate
to the actual screen as a screenwriter
but in terms of how you get people to
work with the production yes
and then fidel castro a lover of the
ocean kind of said you know
this belongs to everyone go ahead and
okay
so that's the more finesse version of it
interesting all right
i think i liked your version better
thinking back to when you worked in the
mail room so you'd gone to afi
you worked in the mail room there's many
people similar spot
and they kind of look around and they
say how long has this person been here
oh yeah i don't want to end up like that
i want to be directing and producing
that's a common thing i think it's a
common trait of youth we think i'm not
going to be that person
40 years old over there working there a
long time how does someone then
get out of that because i'm sure that
many of those people
in those positions they plan the same
thing but then life happens
kids happen mortgages happen and you
can't just say
well i'm going to run off and produce
this when you have a family to support
responsibilities
so how common is that idea
of well i mean it's going to be
different for me i'm going to come here
fresh out of film school or wherever i'm
not going to be that guy over there in
that department
i'm going to make changes uh i think for
everyone that has a dream of being a
show business
there's that moment where you start at
the very bottom at the whatever that
entry level is and it's different for
for everyone but a lot of us started in
a mail room
um and for me i was having
breakfast with my grandfather who uh
was a very important role model in my
life the friday before the monday i had
my first day in the mail room
and uh he said to me what are you gonna
do to get noticed
i said i don't know i'll do a good job
he goes well i'm sure everyone in the
middle wants to do a good job what are
you going to do
to be noticed i said i don't know he
goes what do you plan on wearing
i said it i don't know t-shirt pants
nice pants maybe a collared collared
shirt he goes
no you're gonna wear a jacket and tie i
said in a mail room
he said if you wear a jacket and tie
whoever you're delivering mail to is
gonna look up and go who's this kid
and uh i got there monday everybody was
in like torn metallica or
you know rock and roll shirts and cut
off jeans
and i was there and they that they did
not look kindly on me who's this
kid from film school with the shirt and
tie on
uh and uh the first day
i was delivering mail to this producer
rick rosner who had done
chips and was doing for this company
film ways was doing a show called 240
robert which was
chips in malibu um stalling starring
john bennett perry matthew perry's dad
and uh he looks at me goes who are you
i said this is why i was and he goes
what are you doing here i said i'm
delivering your mail and he goes where
are you from
and i said i just graduated from film
school he goes
give me two weeks and you're gonna work
for me two weeks later he
lived up to us and uh i became his
assistant so
i nope no change in pay but
i no longer was delivering mail i only
delivered mail for about two weeks
and i was his assistant would go around
to the set and go to
production meetings and that led me to
the next job which was as a
answering phones for a casting director
who was doing rocky iii and
a bunch of series for abc and then that
job led me to meet someone at abc
who said you need to get out of the uh
blue collar side of our business below
the line and you need to get above the
line so i'm going to
find you a job as a reader and so a year
later i got a job as a reader
and that started my development career
do you think that's still possible today
i think
what i teach at my class at afi and i
have young students
you know in their 20s and 30s who have
the same dream that i had when i was
sitting at afi and i think the part of
that helps is that i was
i sat in the chair that they sat in and
i really believe
that um you make your own good luck
passion is really important hard work is
really important
respecting the people on your way up is
but yes i absolutely believe that dreams
can still come true mice
i've had quite a few of my students that
have had very successful careers as
producers some as screenwriters
um so yeah i don't 100 believe that
there is
still the chance when i graduated from
afi
the barrier to entry was financial
you couldn't just set up shop and make a
movie you couldn't set up shop and
make a short film you had to have a 16
millimeter 35 millimeter camera
you had to have it developed by kodak
you had to run super
equipment lights and sound and niagara's
and everything was expensive
so nobody was making something on their
own now
my sons run a digital content company
called at phony text which is on
snapchat
facebook youtube instagram
um they have 150 175 million views on
youtube and they've only been doing this
eight months
wow they have no barrier to entry they
make write produce direct
all of their own content and they do it
all themselves in-house
so they have the advantage of making
their dream come true
they're storytellers just like i was
only they're skipping the mail room and
the
because they can do it with a phone i
didn't have that luxury so
i do believe if you know peter guber
told me that
the currency to our industry is good
stories
that if you have one someone is going to
find it
when barry morrow pitched me a story of
a
two brothers one who was mentally
challenged and got inherited all the
money from his father when he died
and the brother that didn't get the
money deciding to kidnap him
he was a tv movie writer and i was a tv
movie producer
and he told it to me and i knew it was a
feature and we walked across the hall to
roger birnbaum who was running goober
peter's features
while i was running goober peter's
television but we all knew it was a
great story
you know at the time we thought we were
going to make it as a little tiny movie
for warner brothers
warner brothers passed it ended up at ua
and of course it also ended up with
dustin hoffman and tom cruise and it
became rain man but you know
it was a good story and it didn't it
didn't come from
a highfalutin very successful
screenwriter it came from a television
movie writer
and didn't come from a feature executive
i was a tv movie executive
so yeah dreams come true
you started taking classes at afi after
brandeis yeah you you went to med school
you said
or you tried to flunked out pre-med
i went straight from brandeis to afi i
graduated
brandeis in may and i started at
greystone mansion which was a really fun
place to go to school which afi isn't
there anymore but
uh the duhedi mansion beverly hills and
i started there in september and uh
i produced a film with a second year
director
and and then had this vision i would get
out and
become a producer immediately and sent
out the film that we had
shot on three-quarter inch tapes to
about i don't know 200 people
and got two meetings and neither one of
those got me a job
one of them uh was with mike matavoy who
at the time was head of orion pictures
and i thought i got this amazing
opportunity and it was because he
happened to know the chairman of the
board of brandeis so
he was doing it kind of as a favor
unbeknownst to me to someone else
and when i got in he said uh pitch me
something
and bri uh if i had never discussed
pitching
and the entire time i was at the
american film institute we had not
discussed it so
i don't know 10 years later i ran into
gene fersenberg who was then running the
american film institute
and she said uh so how did your afi
education go for you i said it was great
except you got to tell these kids how to
pitch
she said why don't you teach that i
started by teaching a couple of weekend
seminars and then they
sent me around the country and i taught
the same seminar in about 10 different
cities
and then eventually they put me on as an
adjunct professor and i've been teaching
that course for about
22 years once a week once a week i teach
a course on
pitching and developing for television
and uh no student graduates afi now
without knowing how to pitch
so what did they implement into the
curriculum aside from that i mean now
because
you know film stock's no longer needed
really i mean it still looks beautiful
but
dslrs and and all these other cameras
are here
well afi's curriculum has changed very
little other than
probably for the cinematography fellows
um you know when i was there it was just
cinematographers directors writers and
producers now there's an editor
uh fellowship and there's a production
design fellowship those are all since i
was there
but the focus at afi has always been
learn by doing and the story comes first
so we're all storytellers we're all
teaching storytelling when i teach
pitching it's all about
concept character and plot um so
i don't think it's changed dramatically
the medium by which you deliver the
story to the audience can change
from 70 millimeter down to digital
bits that are coming across youtube but
in the end
if you don't have a good story to tell
it doesn't matter how gorgeous your film
is or
how many academy award-winning actors
you have in it
if you don't have a good story to tell
it's not gonna work you know if it's
not on the page it's not on the stage
and uh so
we still teach how do you tell a good
story how do you move an audience how do
you make them laugh them cry
then feel something be scared how do you
do that how do you do that
with the medium of film and uh and now
with the medium of
digital what do you think afi offers
that other
colleges don't offer i think because
afi's mission statement
is learn by doing and because so much of
the faculty is like
myself we're like paratrooper professors
we parachute in we teach a class we come
from work
we talk about what's happening right now
in the business
we bring with us guests that are working
right now
and then we go back to our work and so i
think the advantage of
having those kinds of professors not
someone retired who did it
five years 10 or 15 or 25 years ago
not someone who always wanted to teach
but never had success in the business
but by having former fellows and and
people who admire the american film
institute who are still working who
come to the the campus
over there at franklin and western and
teach what they're doing and then the
students go out and take those
fundamental ideas
and then go do it the next day in their
cycle films and then thesis films
i think makes afi different than
everybody else and better
what do you think the advantages are of
taking courses there or or any college
really
versus learning online whether it's
a master class of some sort or or even
just watching other youtubers
i think there is great value
in doing around other people who have
the same
interests and desires that you have and
having a working
faculty that can critique it on the fly
so you can do it online but nobody's
watching that
nobody's staying next to you and you're
not having you know again movies are
made by a village
so if you're not standing with a
screenwriter and fighting with him over
the scene if you're not standing with
the dp and fighting over the lighting
and if you're not standing with the
editor in the editing room and fighting
over a cut and when to go to the master
and when
it's how long to stay in the close-up
you're not learning
what it takes to forge a film because
that conflict is what makes great
filmmaking if it goes perfectly and
everybody gets along and everybody just
does what they're supposed to do
the movie will suck you need that
conflict you need
the movies are forged in that place
where everyone's doing their job
but their job might necessarily be your
job and so the director has a job to do
which is to make great art and to sell
his story
the producer has the job to tell that
story but deliver it to someone who's
paying for it and get them what they
want while still
allowing the filmmaker to do what they
want and the editor wants to bring what
they have to the table and the
screenwriter what they have to the table
and in that collective hurricane is
where great movies are made great
television is made
and so you i think you have to be in
that not to mention
that a rising tide lifts all boats
if you have a classmate who succeeds
early you know two or three years out
and brings you along
that's you know a really important thing
that you don't get if you're
going to a seminar or doing it online
and afi fellows tend to
help each other stan do you watch your
work
do you go and watch reruns or i watch my
work while i'm doing it
i'm incredibly involved especially in
the post-production
i try not to do much on set as a
producer obviously as a director i'm
running this at
but when i get to post if i'm the
producer
i like to do everything i like to be the
person who locks the cut i like to be
there in the scoring session work with
the composer do all the visual effects
sit in the editing room do the color
correct
be there for the mix do that for the
final mix all that i like i
love that part of it i was a musician in
high school i like the music i like the
whole
because i think there's three parts to
making movies that people forget
and my competitors in the television
movie business i think
didn't follow this and i think that's
one of the reasons there's an emmy on my
shelf
and not on other shelves is that there's
three
very distinct parts of making a movie
the first part
is the script and that script is written
to get somebody to give you the money
that's its job the job of that script
is how do we get to make the movie the
script isn't
here's the plan for the film here's what
it should look like here's what it
should be
that job of that piece of paper 120
pages
is to get someone to say you're greenlit
go make the movie now you have
with the money now you have a second
period which is the production period
which is
let's make the movie now whatever's in
that script
may not necessarily you may get a piece
of casting that comes in that you know
what
they're better than what was there we're
going to change that or we
go to the location and that location
doesn't exist you may want a house that
overlooks the water but you know on this
budget
i can't afford a house that overlooks
the budget so overlooks the water so
we're going to find another house
that's where you take what was in the
script and now you have
a production script now you have a
production plan and now you're making
the best movie you can
from that part of the creative process
it's no longer the script
it's now the production script and now
you finish
now you get to the editing room most of
the people in television movies that
i've worked with
will use the script and put the film
together the way the script unfolded
and if there's a star that's the star of
the film
and if there's a plan for flashbacks or
voice over
that's the plan and you put the film
together like that and you give it to
the network
i don't believe in that at all i believe
that now you're wrapped
now you go into the editing room and say
okay what's the best movie i can make
from what we shot not from what we wrote
from what we shot there's going to be
and it happens on every film
there's going to be performances where
you go wow i didn't expect
that that character actor in these five
scenes
steals the scene from the star so don't
cut the scene
staying on the star cut the scene saying
on that because that's who you want to
watch
that's who lights up the screen i've
discovered actors that have gone on to
big careers
they're not always in the in the lead
role but you'd be a fool
not to have the camera on them even on
reaction shots
the same with with with music there may
be a call for a certain kind of music in
a scene
you play it and go that doesn't work
there may be a call for a visual effect
you go that doesn't work so now what you
got to do
is structure the film i've had films
that start
in scene 25 and then flashback to start
at the beginning so you see something
that's going to happen you don't know
what it means
and you don't know where that's going to
take you and then at some point in the
film you catch up to that scene
and i put the film together and go that
doesn't work i don't want to see that at
the beginning it gives it away
plus the fact i'm bored i don't know
what that means so we
lop it off and we start the movie where
it's supposed to start because that's
the film tells you what it's supposed to
be the performances
tell you what the movie's supposed to be
you need to
to move it around if there are puzzle
pieces sometimes and so
that third part which is how you make
the movie in post
i think is part of why my films in the
television movie business
have been more successful higher rated
better reviewed
than most of my competitors and uh you
know that was why
uh my company was called once upon a
time because i was a storyteller i was
gonna be a storyteller from the
first day we start on the script for the
last day we deliver it to the network
so this movie tells you what it's
supposed to be in the edit bay
and then you work within that it's not
that script the initial screen you don't
say too
sort of like married to that one script
correct interesting
okay and sometimes directors on a
television movie
because that's what they directed can't
let go
of that structure or those performances
or
that pacing and so it's my job as the
producer
to be able to separate myself and say
okay
i have this much footage what's the best
movie i can make
it's you know i have all these different
pieces of clay what's the best sculpture
i can make
i'm not going to leave them as blocks
i'm going to mold it into something
that's
perfect or as perfect as can be from
what i'm given
i'm not given what was in the script we
had hoped that that actor was going to
be the star
well as it turns out the other guy in
the movie is a better
performer so i'm going to want to lean
the movie that way i'm not going to just
for pride's sake because i cast this guy
as the lead
and this woman as the co-lead stay on
this side
i let the movie tell me what it should
be i let the movie tell me how it should
be cut how it should be scored how it
should be mixed how it should be color
corrected
it tells you if you pay attention it
tells you as long as you can let go
this is the back to the coloring outside
the lines question as long as you can
let go
of what you wrote and what you thought
you were going to shoot
you know the happy accidents you stuff
happens on set all the time
but those happy accidents aren't
probably in the script
those are things when i directed perfect
sisters with georgie henley and abigail
breslin and mira sorvino
the best image in the entire film was
not in the script
i showed up on set and georgie was
sitting in a classroom by herself
and it was and they were these green
desks elementary school desks and they
were all in rows like a kubrick movie i
mean the geometry of the shot was
amazing
and we were waiting for all of the other
kids to come in because it was a
classroom scene
and georgie was sitting in the middle
seat by herself
and i remember looking at her and
thinking
that's the shot where she decides she's
going to kill her mother
i don't have that in my script i don't
have that in my storyboard i don't have
that in my production plan
and i said to the director shoot that
and i said to georgie
just look down and then look up and
that's probably the most powerful
moment in the film was not in the
production plan was not in the script
and it spoke to me it just all of a
sudden she was there the
the symmetry of the room everything just
said
we have to shoot that have you ever put
uh footage on the editing timeline
with with your editor and whoever else
in the room
and watch the whole thing through and
just sink down and go
we can't use any of this and then
i mean you have to say which which
production but and then over time
shaping it doing you know maybe a couple
new
reshoots it actually turned into
something beautiful well
uh it's interesting as a producer
a lesson i learned and it was maybe the
hardest lesson to learn
as a filmmaker it was pretty much the
hardest lesson i've ever learned
is that the hope you have for what the
movie will be
is never there when you look at the
editor's assembly
there's assembly first of all is the
editor's idea how it should come
together
and there's no score or they've stuck in
some
you know temp there's no sound effects
there's no adr
none of what you do in that third
process
has happened yet and yet i always forgot
and i finally taught myself
don't be depressed when you see the
editor's assembly it's not
going to be that bad as bad as it feels
now
the movie that you thought you were
going to make you can still get there
but this isn't and uh and i learned i
learned quickly
probably after five or six films let
that depression go don't walk in with
the expectation this is going to be a
walk in the expectation
it's not and i forgot it all when i
became a director
and the first cut of the first movie i
directed
i sobbed i said to the other that's
thank you so much i walked in my car
and i cried for an hour i said i am not
a director
i did such a terrible that is such a
terrible movie
if i could throw it all out i could
throw it all out and start again
and then i had to call my friend jeff
loeb who's
the best storyteller i know um and he
said
you've been through this before you've
done this you've made 70 movies
stop you remembered as a producer now
remembered as a director it's just more
personal now
and eventually we worked with it and
worked with it and worked with it and
then i got the movie i wanted but
yeah that was the hardest and i still
even when i just directed an episode of
agents of shield and still when i see
the assembly it's like ah
and then you get there many of your
projects have been in the true crime
genre what attracts you to this well i
think my original attractions to true
crime was
it was going to pay the bills because uh
it was the appetite it was the
meal that the television networks wanted
for a long time i would say half
to maybe more than half of what was on
cbs or
nbc was true crime and then when
lifetime became the
preeminent supplier they wanted true
crime so i think at the start
um it was just that was the world i was
in and that was
i had to learn and then eventually i
realized that i could become a
storyteller in that
world and i didn't have to do it the way
everyone else was doing it which was
kind of a straightforward
police narrative that there were other
ways to tell true crime and
uh so i tried to find the emotional
hook in a true crime movie and so i
would make
stories that weren't as much about the
crime but as much about the
effect it had on the people who either
were the victims or were the
police or were the criminals and
how did their lives change and what were
the emotions they were going through and
um you know we did capture the green
river killer
which tom cavanaugh was nominated for
wars and we won the dgc award
for outstanding miniseries and
that movie is about a man's crisis of
conscience of giving up on god because
for 25 years he would constantly
be finding these murdered young women
in between 15 and 25 in seattle
and he couldn't find this guy and for 25
years he chased this guy
and he was a deeply devoted christian
and at one point he just turned to god
and said you can't possibly exist
if this is what you are allowing to
happen
and you aren't letting me fix it i was
put here to find this guy and arrest him
and stop these women from dying
and that's my calling and i'm not doing
my job so where are you
so we made a movie about that in many
stories about that i still to this day i
think it's the highest rated
miniseries and on element and we want
all kinds of awards and
and uh and the person who wrote it wrote
agnes of god so
that was right in his wheelhouse and i
chose him because
we wanted to explore that as opposed to
what was the crime how did the girls die
how were they killed
how did they find him what was the what
were the clues
it wasn't a detective story it was an
emotional story
how do you find these stories yeah i'm
sure you you scour the news and you
look at what's on goodreads or different
things but what is it that calls to you
about a certain story
the thing that people have to remember
about all genres is
in the end do you care and is it a good
story
it doesn't matter if it's a romantic
comedy or true crime or
a western all of which i've done you
still want to find does it pull out your
heartstrings does it make you feel
something to make you feel angry does it
make you feel sad
does it communicate to you a personal
experience
do you feel for the characters do you
root for the
protagonist do you root against the
antagonist those are all the things that
have to happen in a story
uh i remember a couple of screenwriters
early on would say to me when i started
in the true crime business well this is
what really happened
i said that doesn't matter what really
happened is
almost irrelevant if it's not a good
story if what
really happened is the excuse we have
for not being good storytellers
then we need to get another job it
really happened is not the answer to
a story flaw to not being able to have a
second act twist and not being able to
have a satisfying third act
those things still have to happen even
when you're in true crime
so of course when i could find a great
book as i did with capturing river
killer or
establish a relationship with a great
crime writer like anne rule
who was probably the greatest crime
writer of all time may she rest in peace
uh i would say that also helped because
for instance ann i made three of her
movies she had a nose for
telling a story like nobody i knew and
uh and she again wasn't just interested
in the crime
she was interested in the characters
around the crime and that some of that
came from her own story right with it
sort of put her on the map well anne
rule's story is amazing i mean anne rule
was uh
she was a crime reporter a prime
journalist she her
brother was a cop her dad was a cop i
think her grandfather was a cop and her
uncles were cops
so she grew up in that world she knew
she wasn't going to be a cop so she
decided to be a crime journalist and
i think she wrote under a pseudonym
because women didn't do that then
and i think when she wrote her first
book she wrote it under a pseudonym
and she was living in seattle and she
was volunteering at a
uh suicide hotline and the guy sitting
next to her was a very attractive
guy from the university of washington
was also volunteering they would show up
on the same night every week and talk
they became friends and they would go
out for coffee afterwards and
you know kind of decompress from what
i'm sure was not a fun night
and they became friends and then one day
she turns on a tv and
he's been arrested and it's ted bundy
and so
she had access to him she talked to him
after he was arrested
and she wrote the deliberate stranger i
think was the name of the book and that
put and rule on the map and i think
that's the first time i could be wrong
but it was right around the first time
she put her name her own name and rule
on a book and so she always drew from
that but i did
i did a roblo movie with her i did a
gina gershon movie with her
and both times she was still and these
were books that had been around for
10 years at least she was still in touch
with the victims families
so she called them when we were doing
the movie and said hey we're making a
movie and this is going to play your mom
or your dad or your brother or sister
and uh and then even when we when the
movie came on she called them after it
aired so yeah
she maintained those relationships
they were like her children the books
were like her children and the victims
families were like her children as well
once you find a story that you want to
then have some screenwriter adapt
what are your steps when it becomes to
the true crime genre
well with true crime uh obviously the
first thing you have to do is
break it down and come up with a an
outline and a
treatment so that's the first step with
the screenwriter is what are the story
beats you know
on a broad scale what's the beginning
middle and end
what's the first act second act twist
and third act even if you're working in
an eight act
structure for television movies you're
still in a three-act structure
so that's the first bit is what story
are we telling because
with a lot of them there's you know it
could be a 10 year story or you could
just tell
a sliver of it so you have to decide
what's the story we want to tell
and once we decide like who are we
rooting for who are we rooting against
are we going to see the crimes are we
not going to see the crimes a lot of
a lot of kind of structural bones of the
story you have to figure out first
that's a lot of conversations before you
put pen to paper
and then you come up with a story
outline and then treatment
and then that has to get approved by
whoever's paying for it whether it a
network or studio
and then you write a screenplay and then
um and
you know the first draft is the writer's
draft and that's when he gets to do
whatever he wants or she wants
um and then from that point forward now
it's you know it's
takes a village so now the networker
studio gets their votes and
i get my notes and you know if we get it
to an actor the actor gets their notes
and so at that point farm now you're
in that place of how do we get this made
and so now you're
adjusting that story in that screenplay
and then when you get ordered
there's a whole other process that you
don't have in fiction which is you now
have to go to the arizona omissions
lawyer
and go through the script page by page
line by line
period by period and make sure that what
you're telling
is true and you haven't defamed anyone
and so there's a lawyer that forces the
screenwriter
to annotate their script page by page
every single thing in it has to be
based on something and if it's fiction
like if they say okay well there's a cop
and we know that
he was went home and figured it out at
home but there's no
we know that because the next day he
went in and made an arrest
but we don't have any actual
documentation that he went home and
figured it out
but we're gonna write a scene where he
goes home and figures it out and that's
that's the connective tissue between
when he doesn't catch the killer and he
does catch the killer
well they'll allow a certain amount of
that in your screenplay
maybe 10 20 um if the audience pays
attention
they'll know how much is fiction because
on a television movie if it says based
on a true story
it's almost completely true there's very
little fictionalization
if it says inspired by true events or
inspired by a true story that means the
insurance company
and the lawyers have said you took
too many liberties we're still going to
say true story but we're not going to
say based on we're going to say inspired
by
and uh that allows you more lead way i
always tried
to get to based on i liked my movies to
be as close to the truth as possible
uh perfect sisters was based on a true
story uh capture the renewable killer
was based on a true story
um so i i i always fought
to get as close to the based on moniker
as possible but
it wasn't always the case if there's a
book out
about the case are you then going to the
author
to adapt it and get their rights or do
you have to get the life story rights
of the individual or the state of
whomever
is is is involved in the story so the
important thing to remember
when you're doing true crime that's
based on a book
is if you're optioning the book and you
don't have to
if you're optioning the book the book
doesn't come with any rights
so if you're going to do a story about
i did this movie the grim sleeper for a
lifetime which i directed and produced
and it was based on the work of a
journalist at the la weekly a young
woman who was a fact checker and figured
out
that there was a serial killer preying
on african-american women in south
central los angeles
she figured it out she wasn't even a
journalist yet she was a fact checker
from ottawa canada
and she put the pieces together and they
let her write the piece and they
eventually caught him
because of her work and she hadn't
written a book
she had written a bunch of essays for la
weekly
i didn't need anything except her
i didn't need the la weekly articles i
didn't need the la weekly there was no
book
there have been stories in the la times
there have been stories in the la daily
news
so i had plenty of source but i needed
her
so she was the rights i had to go get so
i skipped over all the writing about the
grim sleeper and i went right to the
source and i got her rights that allowed
me to depict her
it also allowed me to have her talk to
the screenwriter and tell them the
entire story
which is what she did the screenwriter
tina booth brilliant screenwriter
spent time with christine palasek who
was the real woman and she told her her
story
so that's it's important because people
think when they buy a book or they buy a
magazine article they buy a newspaper
accounting of something
that they're getting something with that
all you're getting is the point of view
of that author now that may be important
and if they're the sole source then you
do need it because you can't source it
from anywhere else
but if it's a big story and it's been
it's been
uh recorded and reported elsewhere in
like three or four or five sources you
don't need a book you don't
you don't need a magazine article you
just need but if you're going to depict
somebody as your heroine or hero
you do need their rights because you
can't really depict somebody unless
they're super famous
without their rights you can do the
michael jackson or elvis story without
rights
but you can't do the christine palisac
story without rights i needed the
sheriff david reichert who was the
sheriff in
seattle who broke the green river killer
case i needed his rights
what constitutes how famous someone is
because you know you could have
youtubers
some of whom could be famous to a
certain age group and then
older populations wouldn't like they'd
have to be famous to a level where there
has been
so much coverage of them that the
insurance company would feel like
it's impossible to defame them because
they have been in the public eye
at such a high level youtubers would not
qualify
um uh you know they have to be at the
elvis level
sure okay john f kennedy orlando
somebody who's whose whole life has been
in the public eye and there's hundreds
and hundreds of
magazines and newspapers and
documentaries then you can
get i mean i think most of the elvis and
michael jackson movies and
for television and mini series for
television we're done without rights
call me the rise and fall of heidi flies
you did a movie on heidi fleiss back in
what year was that 1990s
2000 000 okay okay um
we all know what the story's about but
what about the story behind the story of
getting some of the
talent attacks so uh that's a great
story i
had made a bunch of movies true crime
movies for jeff wachtel who was a friend
and he was at the time running the usa
network which
didn't make a lot of television movies
but when they did they generally did
pretty well
and one of the things that jeff told me
is they would
routinely in their staff meetings come
up with ideas for television movies
and they would make a poster of it and
they would go to
like 10 malls in the midwest and they
would put the posters up and have people
come over and
all they would see is the title and some
image and they would say
which of these movies would you want to
see most and which would you like to see
least and
rank them and he said one
after another every time we do this the
title
that comes back the highest is the heidi
fleisch story
but we don't have a handle on it so he
said but you're such a
good storyteller would you do the heidi
fly story
and i said to him if you're thinking
cradle to grave like how did she become
heidi fleiss and what did she do and who
were her clients
i'm not interested he said was there a
story
you are interested in telling i said
well let me think about it
i thought about it i thought about it
and then i woke up one morning and
i was like on a run or something then
bingo i thought of it and i called him
back and i said
if you'll let me make uh
all about eve in the world of
high-priced call girls in beverly hills
because the store or the true story is
that heidi stole the business
from the legendary madam before her who
was madame alex who
had all the studios and all the
producers and all of them
and heidi was one of her girls and then
heidi called the cops had madame
alexander arrested for a 24-hour hold
and during that 24 hours
she stole every client and by the time
madame alex got out of prison
jail county jail in beverly hills jail
heidi had her business and how he went
from being a call girl to a madam
so he said if you let me do all about
eve because that's an interesting story
then i'm interested and he goes go ahead
and brenda fricker played madame alex
and jamie lynn siegler played
and that was pretty high-priced talent
for me brenda frick was an academy award
winner and
jamie ziegler was on the sopranos at the
time we thought
what better than a jewish girl from long
island playing a jewish girl from
encino and it worked great
shouldn't an executive producer know
more about money than they should about
storytelling
well an executive producer if they're
doing their job right should know just
as much about storytelling as they
are about money because whoever giving
them the money
has an expectation of what story you're
going to tell them so
there's a script that they've given you
the money for
so it's now your job to deliver that
at the price that they gave you so yes
it's very important you know how to
put financing together and know how to
deal with banks and loans and
tax credits and advances and all of that
on the other hand
the person who's giving you the money
has an expectation that the director is
going to direct
the movie that they bought the actors
are going to act the movie that they
bought
and so the only person that's going to
make sure that that train doesn't run
off the tracks
is the executive producer so the line
producer's real job is
what time is it and are we done the line
producer job is just make sure okay i
have this much money to spend on this
day and that's what we're going to spend
he doesn't have any creative
responsibility nor should he it's the
upm and the
line producer's job to get it done at
the price
so it's the executive producer who has
to kind of be the referee
between the part that's pulling for
money
being saved and the part that's pulling
for let's do the best movie possible and
that's the director's job is
not to worry about the money you don't
want them to think about money you want
them to think about
what's the best movie i can make and you
want your line producer to say
you can't do that because we can't
afford it and so someone has to referee
and get the best movie possible for the
price so how do we
get the very best movie the very best
art
for the price tag that we've been given
that's the executive producer's job
so i don't think you need to know one or
the other more i think you actually need
to know the more you
can do both of those jobs i think the
easier it is to mediate
what's the most common question your
students ask you
i think the most common question my
students ask me is who is the
worst actor you've ever worked with um
but i think that my students biggest
question
is what do we do when we graduate
what's the world that's out there for
them and i think it's my job
to give them the tools to be able to
succeed whether they
get hired initially on the line
producing side
or on the executive producing side or as
a studio executive
a lot of my students go on to be
development executives because they've
learned
how to hear a pitch and to pitch
themselves the thing about pitching is
it's not just
when you go to sell it to a studio or
network you're going to pitch an agent
you're going to pitch a star you're
going to pitch a cinematographer you're
going to pitch an editor hey
i want you to come aboard this project
let me tell you a story so
you're pitching all the time no matter
what part of the business you're in
so to not have that skill in your to not
have that arrow in your quiver is a
just a i think a huge detraction to your
career and it would be remiss upon us as
filmmaking professors not to give you
that
so the continuation of storytelling not
just
within the confines of 120 page script
but with someone to allow you to come in
and pitch to them
with someone that you're sending out the
script to that's a potential investor
you know everything is scary when you
leave film school it's all
frightening will i succeed will i make
it will i be the one that
gets to live out the dream and i think
it's part of our responsibility as
experienced filmmakers and professors to
try and
[Music]
calm some of those fears by telling them
what it's going to be like to give them
realistic expectations
but also to give them enough tools that
no matter what situation they get in
whether they're
making the movie on their phone for 25
or they get hired to do you know 25
million
sequel to something that they have those
tools
and all of it comes back to storytelling
what about the definition of the dream
do you think it's the same for most of
the students do you think they're
skewed by wanting their picture in
variety
whereas people can be working in the
industry they have work all year long
maybe people don't know them as a
household name but they're still living
out being creative
being on a set i think the most
disappointed you will
be in our business if you live for the
fame and the fortune
um i had to learn that lesson the hard
way
peter cooper was helpful in teaching me
that
that really the reason we do this
is the process if you don't enjoy the
doing
if you don't enjoy every part of getting
that script
ordered into production and then going
on a set and then sitting in an editing
room or sitting on a mixing stage
that's the part um i got depressed after
i saw my first
credit on screen i lied awake all night
not understanding why i wasn't happier
and took some therapy and a couple of
conversations with peter guber to figure
out
that that wasn't the be-all end all
seeing my name on the screen for the
first time which is what i thought it
would be
it was the getting to do it to see my
name on the screen
which is also part of why i don't love
watching my stuff
again and i think it's the doing that i
love
and then when it's over it's over and
i'm on to the next i want to know what
the next challenge is going to be
i don't love watching stuff that's
already
been made because that was the process
then and i want to find the new process
i want to find the new road to get on
and do you think your sons saw you that
you instilled that in them somehow
whether it was just
by them watching you because they have
this successful channel and so many
people set out to have a youtube channel
they don't reach that level i think
that my sons had the benefit of being
around really good storytellers in their
house
whether it was me whether it was their
mother who also is in the business of
telling stories at uh television movie
network whether it be screenwriters that
were friends of miami
their godfather runs marvel television
um
and they were blessed to hear him tell
stories all the time um
and then we you know we made it a point
to you can't come home from school and
just say
uh it was a good day you got to tell me
a story so i think they were in
they were you know indoctrinated with
storytelling at a young age and i think
they were blessed to have really good
storytellers around them
telling stories that they could hear it
and soak it up like little sponges and
um yeah they went to really good schools
that taught them how to be
good storytellers as well that
definitely helped um
both of their colleges are great liberal
arts colleges i'm a big believer in not
going to film school as an undergrad
i don't think you learn what you need in
undergraduate film
i think if you want to take graduate
course if you want to go and get an m.a
or mfa
that's great and i think afi and usc and
nyu and ucla are great afi the best
but i don't think as an undergrad that's
what you should be doing i think as an
undergrad you should be
taking literature and architecture and
art classes i mean i can tell you
i don't use my film school knowledge
anywhere near as much as i use my
undergraduate
brandeis degree i i will tell you that
if i'm sitting with a composer
i'm not going to talk about frames per
second we're going to talk about bach
and beethoven and
talking heads i mean that's what a
musician wants to talk about well that's
stuff i learned
in college not in film school if i'm
with a
set designer what i learned in my one
architecture class
comes in handy when i see with a
screenwriter you know what i learned in
english lit and history and social
studies and politics that all comes in
handy
not you know how much does it cost to
put a light on a set and what is what
are the fringes for a
screenwriter you know that's important
and i
i love my afi education if you're gonna
be a good filmmaker and a good
storyteller
you really do need a liberal arts
education would you rather produce a
movie or
executive produce a movie well in the
television movie business which i was in
for
20 years you really don't have a choice
you have to be both you have to be the
executive producer and the line producer
as executive producer supplier the
person who's the studio who the network
is
counting on for that film and who is at
risk for
deficit and who has put together the
financing from international money and
tax credits you're responsible for the
whole kit and caboodle so
and delivering what the person who's
paying for it wants
so that's the executive producer side
and the supplier side
but then on the other hand you gotta you
gotta make sure there is no going over
in television movies so
uh and probably in the independent
feature business as well you if
you've got a 17-day schedule or a 15-day
schedule you're finishing in 15 days
so that's the line producer side is is
where do you spend the money
what i tend to find is the most
enjoyable part of that
is what does this movie call for how do
we move you can't use a standard well
this is how much we normally spend on
wardrobe this is how much we normally
spend on
you know hair and makeup this is what we
normally spend on picture cars
you know some movies require more of one
or the other some movie require lots of
extra summary requires no extras
so you want to make sure that you take
the money available to you
and put it on the screen so we're always
moving stuff around we're moving it from
okay we don't really need that many
extras so let's take that extra money
and get more wardrobe you know the heidi
fly story which we talked about
was wall to wall wardrobe i mean there
was so much wardrobe and lingerie and
all that which are all very expensive so
i had to find that money somewhere so
where was i going to find the money
was i could have less locations was
going to have less extras was i going to
have
less crew on some days where i could
figure out a way to get the crew down
what was the way i was going to be able
to save that money
you also took a class at afi from
another producer a gentleman who had
been in the business for years
he was a producer i thought i had read
that okay maybe not
when i was a student we were taught the
line producing
business from a working
just which is the same as it is now so
there was a working
uh upm and a working a d and it was a
year-long class
online producing the first semester
we would take a script a real script
that this
upm had worked on at paramount in fact
and break it down so we would break it
down and
do and put a board together in those
days we actually used real strips now
it's all done on
movie magic but we had real strips and
we would put day exterior knight
exterior day interior night interior
inserts visual effects and put those
strips onto a board and then
we would bring it into class and he
would look at our board after breaking
down
and so that was the first semester and
then the second semester we would take
that board
with an ad who taught the second
semester
and they were the upm and ad that always
worked together
and then we budgeted from that board so
by the time you finished your one year
of the line producing class you had
broken a script down
boarded it and budgeted it and so by the
time i graduate afi
i could blind produce pretty good
has line producing and and just
executive producing everything changed
so going back to that time are the rules
and the ways of finding money
and and cutting costs here and there
pretty much the same
or things slightly different i think the
costs have
gone up and yet efficiencies have gone
way down so
you know the as i said the barrier entry
is no longer money so
you couldn't really make a television
movie for
a hundred thousand dollars there just
was no way between equipment and
guilds and whatever and just the cost of
doing it you just couldn't do it but now
people make
movies that get released as features for
a hundred thousand dollars so
the economies are there because of
digital primarily i mean film was
raw stock was really expensive and
developing was really expensive and
you know just being in an editing room
where you'd have to put
uh clips up on a hook where instead of
just having digital you know
it used to be and i caught on film from
my first five television movies i think
we caught on film and you would say to
the editor
let's try it with you know a close-up
here and let's try this scene with the
let's go back to the wide and let's
let's get rid of these two shots in this
scene and then he'd say
okay disappear for two hours or go get
lunch or go get dinner or come back
tomorrow
and that's what you do and now you sit
in any room on what used to be an avid
and now final cut pro and
okay what do you think of that it's
right there right then right that moment
so that's changed what's the difference
between being a hollywood producer and
an independent film producer
well i think a hollywood producer has
uh more of a studio life and studio life
is very different than an independent
life because student life is
you have a deal at a studio and you
bring them projects and it's either a
first look or an exclusive deal and
agencies are feeding you material
because they know that you have
a straight shot to getting it financed
because you're on a lot and
so i think that's a hollywood it's a
little bit of a throwback to the old
days of the studio system
you have the advantages of a you know a
very muscular studio that's going to
provide you with
access to material and access to crews
and
sound stages and visual effects
companies
and as an independent you're putting it
all together every time it's
mickey rooney and judy garland let's put
on a show and it's you
start from the very beginning and you
got to find someone to pay for the
script
you got to find someone to pay for the
movie and every little piece of it has
to be put together by you you
it's a giant lego box of legos and you
have
basically no instructions and you've got
to build you know
hogwarts castle out of memory and uh
imagination and so
it's all you know the independent life
is the
you know traveling salesman you it's
every single day you have to be doing it
there's no luxury there's no sitting
back there's nothing coming to you
um i think the hollywood studio producer
has
some luxuries and obviously there's some
disadvantages which is
there's probably a lot of stories you
don't get to tell um
especially nowadays you know if it's not
a comic book or a sequel
i think you know the studio producer
probably is at a disadvantage in some of
the stories they get to tell
and if they're an exclusive deal and
there's a story they want to tell and
the
studio they're at passes they're kind of
sol
and so um there's obviously pros and
cons to being a
hollywood producer and being an
independent producer
was it chris christopherson freedom
isn't free
freedom is another word for nothing left
to lose oh i thought that was uh janice
joplin
no that was chris christopher me and
bobby mcgee which janice joplin sang
okay all right i made five movies with
chris
picked
oh nice okay but my point with that was
that
even with with so-called freedom it's
you know that it comes at a cost so
and then studio system maybe not as much
freedom yeah
but but then i think it's the single
best lyric written in an american song
in the last 50 years
freedom is just another word for nothing
left to lose yeah
the janice joplin story is fascinating
too yeah
you never want to do something on her i
find the bio movies are really hard to
do
really i think they're better served in
documentaries and the people that do
them well
i found them difficult i i prefer
because do you go right you know cradle
to grave do you
pick a slice of life do you right you
know that's true
and again i am not i don't believe
because it happened makes it a good
story there are people that have great
lives that belong in documentaries that
don't belong in
i mean look i get pitched every week if
not every day somebody's saying
i have an amazing story to tell you and
they tell me a story of someone they
knew or someone they read about
and it is a probably a good 60 minutes
piece or maybe even a good documentary
for netflix
but it's not a movie because a movie is
different than a documentary
how active are you in pursuit for your
next story
on a daily basis i'm always open
to whatever the next story is going to
be now that i've transitioned from being
a producer
to a writer director um
now i'm much more picky and i'm not open
to just what'll sell
or what i think the marketplace needs
now i'm looking for just something that
really
moves me and i feel will
be something i want to dive deeply into
for a long period of time
as a producer i could skim along the
surface i never had to
dive in that deep but as a writer or
director or both
it's a deep dive and i have to be
willing to commit to that and feel that
i can bring something to it and i'm
going to enjoy those characters
i will say that one of the great joys
i've learned
late in my career as a writer is that
moment when you're
sitting in front of that black screen
and this characters start to speak for
themselves
and they come alive on your page and
that's you know i didn't get to do that
as a producer
and so i'm really enjoying that part of
it so
um i'm always open i find you know
stories can come from
anywhere um so i'm always open but now
much pickier you know when i was running
my own little studio
at once upon a time films we were making
three or four television movies a year
i had to find lots of material if we
were
running a three to one development to
film ratio i had to have
you know nine scripts ready to go for
every
three movies i got made so that meant
if i had to have nine scripts ready to
go i had to have
20 ideas ready to get scripted or 30. so
it was we were always looking for
stories i'm much less
interested now in that kind of volume
now i want to find something that
has a wow factor does that wow factor
come to you right away
or will it kind of fester late at night
you'll like
be up you're like you know what actually
i do like this story i wasn't short
first but then
it kind of like festers in your mind a
little i think there's i think they're
both there's there's certainly
the wow factor of that's the most
amazing thing i've ever heard and
well i have to have that i have to have
that right now how do i get that story
how do i get that book or magazine or a
true life story
when i when i heard the story of
christine palisac
being a fact checker at 23 years old and
working at la weekly and
breaking the grim sleeper uh serial
killer in los angeles
i i didn't need to know anymore but then
there's stories that will
i just can't let go i'll go back to and
go back to them but it was the
the hopefully the next movie i'm going
to make
in the amazon was a story that i chased
for five years
and uh it was a true life story and i
just couldn't let it go
and some other producer got it and
failed at developing it and i would call
every six months and
after about a year and a half they
abandoned the other producer
and went with me and uh it really i just
could not let it go it was a story i had
to tell
one way or the other i was going to tell
that story sorry stan is that your next
project that you're referring to
i believe my next film will be uh the
girl who fell from the sky
and that's the true story of julianne
kepcke who in 1972 was living
in peru going to the american school she
was 18
was in her senior year her parents were
noted zoologists she had lived part of
her childhood in the
amazon her parents were cataloging
butterflies and bats
and then when she got to middle school
they moved her to lima and she grew up
there spoke
perfect german perfect english perfect
spanish
and uh because it was uh
they're on a different schedule than us
because their seasons are different than
us
their school year ends in december so
she was both
graduating and going to her prom in
december
and uh her dad wanted them to go to the
amazon
on christmas eve and she wanted to stay
and so he went early and she and her mom
stayed behind in lima and she went to
her prom
graduated with her friends and then they
got on a plane
and when the plane was over the amazon
it was hit by lightning twice
and disintegrated in midair and she was
in the window seat still strapped in
and as she said the i didn't leave the
plane the plane left me and she found
herself
at 15 000 feet in her chair upside down
pinwheeling and uh she
fell blacked out fell hit the canopy of
the amazon which broke her fall
it's a miracle absolutely she's the
longest free fall without a parachute
and the canopy
broke her fall and she uh landed in the
amazon
woke up had nothing but a broken
collarbone that she knew of
she had one shoe lost her glasses and
for the next
nine days followed the river and the
lessons that she learned from her father
and her own desire not to die
and was rescued and she's a friend of
mine now she's now in her 50s
and she's an extraordinary woman she
spends half her year in munich
and the other half of the amazons trying
to save the rainforest
and uh we're gonna go down to bogota and
uh
and and the amazon and hopefully tell
that story at the beginning next year
wow
are you able to break down a script in
terms of when a script is submitted to
you for you to consider
what are you looking at how are you sort
of dissecting it to see if it will work
i try and read a script that's sent to
me
as an audience first so
the first thing i'm looking at is it
does it grab me do i care
is it a story that can i feel emotional
about compelled by
you know if it's a scary movie am i
scared
if it's a comedy have i laughed if it's
emotional have i
you know gotten a lump in my throat um
i find that if i'm looking at it and
dissecting it right from the start
i'm i'm not doing myself any favors and
i'm not doing the script any favors
if i get to i don't know at some point
it hasn't done any of those things i
usually don't finish it
but if i get to the end and i have felt
those things
then i'll go back and do a second read
as
with my producer hat on which is is this
affordable can we do this will there be
a part in it for a star
which is you know things that things
that are too ensemble
are difficult to get made because you
need a star role
to get things ordered usually so you
know i'm looking i have then i
definitely have one and
then the producer hat goes okay what
where would i shoot this how much is it
going to cost
is there a star role where would was
there a network or studio that would buy
this because you don't want to
obviously chase something that there's
no place to sell and
so then that's the second read what are
some things in a script that sort of
stick out as red flags
whether it's too many locations or even
just
the way the script is written too much
space on the page too little
well you can immediately tell when a
script has not been written by a
professional and obviously that
that's a big red flag so if the script
has
like art on the title page or colored
paper
or is not in final draft form
um you know too much too much of a
header or too much
on the sides and you know okay this
person is either trying to
get something to be shorter or longer by
using the margins which
that's not playing fair so
uh so those are but i would say red
flags are things like
you know not introducing your
protagonist
in the first 10 pages not you know
announcing what your film is
you know in the first 15 pages
um you know don't don't wait until
halfway through to tell me oh this
movie's about this guy who wants to kill
his mom
okay well i'm not sitting here for an
hour waiting for you to tell me that
so um so i'm looking for the kind of
structural and character problems
that are pretty easy to spot um you know
i'm not a big believer in the
robert mckee world of inciting incident
and all that
but there's value in what he has to say
sort of philosophically which is that
there are
some kind of foundational things you
need to do in a screenplay that you
i don't you know unless you're doing
experimental movies
which i'm not in that business uh if you
have a story to tell
there's certain you know parts of the
road map you gotta hit
and um so if you know you
hold back your protagonist until page 30
and that's just
not going to happen there's no you're
not acting a mood
asking a movie star to show up a half
hour into the movie
so those are the kinds of things i look
for when you say you read it as an
audience member first does that mean
you're not even reading it let's say at
your desk on a computer you're trying to
see it as
in more of a reclining position just
more comfortable or no
it just in your mindset i i'm
sadly very old school i'm the get off
your lawn guy so
i forced my uh
my development executive gia to print
everything i
don't like to read anything on my
computer or on my
ipad i like to have the script in my
hand
i like to have tangible i want to be
able to write things on it when
um when i'm reading it especially if i'm
going to read it a second time
as a producer there's going to be things
i'm going to note as i'm
reading and uh so i i like to have a
finished script so and i'll read it on a
plane i'll read it today i'll read it on
out in the backyard
um i don't care where it is but i really
like
plain reading because nobody can bother
me i do
i don't like to read a script in fits
and starts
i prefer to just read it straight
through and it's hard to do that
here in my office i really can't it's
not so easy at home either
there's a query i mean i find plane
travel to be a luxury because there's no
one
calling me nobody finding me nobody
tapping me on the shoulder no emails no
nothing
so i do a lot of good reading on planes
that's really interesting hopefully your
your plane mate that's sitting next to
you is isn't looking to talk about
sports or something yeah
but that's it there you go the right
that's the do not universal do not
deserve
exactly but that i can relate to that or
a book it's a much different experience
i don't like to read a book on an ipad
my wife has a kindle my son has a kindle
i'm
not a kindle person i like to have a
book sure there's a different experience
to holding that
in your hand and i'm sure even with
paper as maybe non-recycling friendly
i'm i have the l.a times delivered at my
house i don't like to read the newspaper
online i'd much rather have
you know i like flipping back and forth
i like having the access to
i'm reading the sports section to go
back to the standings and find out what
place the dodgers are in when i'm
reading the article on the dodgers if
i'm doing that online i got to click
back and click back and it's
it's way less i like the tangible
feeling of moving through a paper i
i would miss that well it's similar to
wanting to see a film with an audience
instead of on your phone or or yes a
laptop
it's not the same 100 right the shared
experience of watching a movie
is completely unique one of the things i
love about
uh being a director is i get to
experience the film more than i do as a
producer and as a television movie
producer it was the worst
because we'd finish our movie we turned
it over the network it would go out and
we'd have
no sense of did people laugh where they
were supposed to laugh did they cry
where they're supposed to cry were they
scared when they were supposed to get
scared
i didn't get to experience any of that
but if i do a feature or an indie
feature
um i get to go into a theater and watch
oh did it work did what i
you know and then stand outside and you
know when
when i did perfect sisters and uh it was
a movie about
two brilliant young high school students
who
came up with the perfect crime to kill
their alcoholic mother
who was a train wreck i
my goal was to get you to the end of
that film and even after they committed
this crime
to still be somewhat sympathetic to the
two girls
and my favorite thing was to stand
outside the theater and hear people
argue with each other
they should have gone to prison they
shouldn't have gone to prison should
have gone for longer they shouldn't have
gone for long
that's why that's what you want you want
them to walk out and be
at odds with with what the story you
just told as opposed to walking out and
be bored
or have no no sense of um
outrage or anger or or contentment
or happiness you know just to have to on
way is the worst thing you can ask from
an audience
do you ever fly to different cities and
get out of sort of an industry-based
town
if i can i love to go to other cities um
and watch but again i came from the
television movie business so
of the 60 movies and series
i've only done three features so most of
what i got
i got from uh relatives calling me going
hey i saw your movie or one email came
out you know friends and family or when
facebook came out
hey i saw your movie but i don't get to
get the visceral
response which i really miss um i'll
tell you
i directed an episode of agents of
shield in season five
and uh again no you know goes out and i
don't know
and it was gia that told me that there's
a whole youtube channel where people
watch something on television primarily
series
and videotape themselves it was
fantastic so now
i got to watch people watch my work
it's great i mean as a tv movie producer
we never get that
we never get that i mean i would have
screenings of
all of my films before it aired on abc
nbc cbs fox
tnt whatever mtv whatever i was working
for i would screen it the week before
for friends and family i would rent a
theater and screen it because
it was the only time i was ever going to
see the audience reaction
i mean i did i did john candy's last
film which he directed and starred in
called hostage for a day for fox
um that was a balls out comedy and it
was it was joke joke joke joke joke
character comedy and the only way i was
going to know if people
laughed where they were supposed to
laugh was to have a screening and we had
a big screen we had a big we
rented a big theater and got a big
audience and i got to see them laugh
when they were supposed to laugh
which hopefully john was there somewhere
in spirit enjoying it as well
how do you know a story is great well
how do i know a story is great that's a
good question i have to trust my
instincts in my gut i think
uh for me spending a
childhood in high school years and
college years watching
lots and lots and lots of movies gave me
a film language
that i think allows me to spot a good
story
i've seen so many really good movies and
so many bad movies
um and read so many scripts and so many
bad scripts that
i think the experience of that kind of
indoctrinated me to
spotting something when it's special
i think if the longer you walk in the
wilderness the easier it is to
spot a forest or water i think and so
for me
i have a very in-depth film language
from having watched
endless black and white movies from the
30s and 40s and
50s so i think that i mean i've watched
every movie on the afi 100 for example
um so i think that helps i think it also
helps them recognize
something that's too similar to
something or oh well that's an homage to
and
you know okay and either either they've
done it well or they haven't done it
well
um and i you know there's certain
filmmakers like billy wilder who
uh who i would love to pattern my
directing career after
who i admire so deeply and so i think
you know
following their instincts and reading
what they did
what they thought i think informs my
decisions as well
how do you know if a script is ready for
financing well that's a great question
how do i know if script is ready for
financing
um i gotta pay bills i mean the truth is
i think it's
you know it's real subjective and i
think it's instinct because
the truth is uh you know if you're in an
editing room
you could edit forever there's no end to
when it
you need a you need a delivery date
delivery into forms
and i think pressures and forges the
best movie you can make
during that time uh it's not open-ended
and i think the same is true with
screenplays i think the better
screenplays are the ones that have to be
made
within a time frame and so at a certain
point you have to sort of say okay
this is the best we're going to do to go
get the financing right now we can't
play with this for another year
now is the time this move this is sort
of reached the time when it's
either we're not going to make it we're
not going to send it out
or it's ready and um i tended to i think
i tend to have a reputation of sending
in scripts to networks
when i was in the television movie
business as a producer that i could get
behind
so i would not send it in much to the
secret of screenwriters often
until i thought i could defend it and if
i couldn't defend it
then i would have the right to do more
work and if i could defend it then i
would send it in
and there were a rare occasion where the
writer would do no more work
and was unwilling to to fix it and uh
and i think i scored a lot of points
because i would tell the network
my candid feelings so i wouldn't send
something in as a lot of my
competitors do and say everything's
brilliant um i would send something in
if
the writer hadn't done the work um and
say look
uh this is not in good shape i'm sending
it to you because i
i can't get the writer do any more work
but um this isn't ready yet
normally i wouldn't show this to you
so you you're a believer in multiple
drafts of notes
and revisions things like that oh
screenplays are not written they are
rewritten the best
screenplays have been rewritten and
rewritten there is no such thing as a
brilliant first draft that goes to
screen unless maybe you're david kelly
but that's no movies are rewritten
not written all of the the
the problems in the script get solved in
rewriting all of the character issues
get solved and rewriting
all the production issues get solved in
rewriting you don't want to throw money
at a problem you want to solve it on the
page
so uh yeah i'm a really big believer in
yes multiple drafts and then there's you
know there's again the draft that gets
your movie ordered
and then there's the draft that you
shoot those are not the same
and then by the time it makes it to the
editing
and it's on the timeline it's the script
yeah
it's totally different it's a different
beast yep and so
is that one thing that you tell your
students is to not be so precious with
whatever was the final version of the
script versus what
well i have producing students not
screenwriting well i have screeners as
well but primarily
i'm teaching producers and uh i critique
their stuff
pretty strongly when they pitch in my
class
so they don't have a choice they can't
be precious in my class
do you also teach them to have tough
skin to to think yeah
i there's a ten commandments that i
teach them on pitching and
one of them is be strong but
take a punch you know the truth is you
want to be back in that room again so
even if they're passing
you want that experience to be positive
so
you know even if they're saying no find
a good moment in that meeting so that
when you call back again
a year from now and you got another
project they don't go
that was the guy that fought with us um
so
i think you want to make sure that any
pitching experience is a good experience
for both people
whether you sell it or not and the truth
is you know you're not going to sell
most of what you know you only need
you can get 99 knows as long as you get
one yes so the truth is you've got to be
resilient you've got to get up off the
mat and i think that is
i think there are producers that are
better at that than talented and that's
their skill
is that they just are relentless and
doesn't matter how people say no they
just keep going they don't care
they have they're able to just get
knocked down and get back up and take a
punch from mike tyson and get back up
and take another punch with mike tyson
get back up
um i'm not that resilient uh i i take
you know i take passes a little more
personal less so now than i did in my
early in my career but
yeah i had to learn how to have a tough
skin but
if you if you're if you definitely can't
handle no
then you're in the wrong business well
going back to rain man
you were told initially no and then you
you kept going and obviously
that worked yeah with rain man we
pitched it to warner brothers and warner
brothers
said we just bought a project similar to
this called forrest gump
from steve tisch and uh so we're not
gonna buy your project
and uh we went out and pitched it to
someone else and then we pitched it to
united artists and united said yes
and then there was the long gestation
after dustin hoffman and tom cruise
committed because we went through four
directors before we actually ended up
making the movie
it was went through steven spielberg and
marty brest
and sydney pollock before we ended up at
barry levinson
so it was like four years of rewriting
and rewriting and rewriting and then
directors leaving the project
before we actually got it made why do
you think the industry saw it as a as a
competitor to forrest gump
two separate stories uh well the
executive at warner brothers saw it as
similar because it was about a mentally
challenged person
whether they were simple or actually
truly autistic and
sort of autistic spawned as rain man was
so i think that's why and they had
bought a book
they paid apparently a pretty penny for
the book with steve tisch and so
they just decided they didn't want to
develop the irony is
um and i'm sure people at warner
brothers don't forget
um that forrest gump got made at
paramount and rayman got made at united
artists and they both won best
picture and neither both got pitched at
warner brothers and both got past
warner brothers they developed the
script in ferrous gump and then didn't
make it and then they passed on
the idea of rain man
how do you make a deal with an actor
well actor deals are made
with the agent so you never make deal
with the actor so
uh it now depends on whether or not
you're
it's an offer or they've come in to read
so um
generally with stars or like you know
number one on the call sheet or number
one and two on the call sheets so the
two biggest parts in the script those
are probably going to be offers only
so um you put a list together with a
casting director and
you get approval from your financer
whether it be a studio or a network
and you call the agent and you make the
you try and make an opening offer
that's going to probably be lower than
what they expect and
where you give yourself a little wiggle
room to go up um and that's uh sort of
and then you know how much you can spend
and so then you get into a negotiation
if they
if they read the script and want to do
it um then there are the rules that
you know the casting director has
sessions you go in and watch
20 or 30 actors play a part and then
pick one
and hopefully those deals are very easy
to make because
they've come in already and read for you
so you know they want to do it and
they kind of know how much money is in
the budget for that role
do you think a movie has to have at
least one star or maybe more
uh i don't think it's up to me whether
or not a movie has a star i think that's
up to the person who's
financing it so internet if you're on a
feature the international marketplace
will dictate
whether or not they want to star and
certainly the studio or network
you didn't make a television movie
without at least one recognizable
star sometimes more than one i rarely
made a television movie where
there wasn't somebody that you knew
either from movies or television really
well
um whose name or you know immediately
rang true as somebody you knew or had
seen
i think in the independent feature
business you have more luxury because
you have a captive audience you know in
television they got to tune in
and stay so you have this problem which
is
i'm going to flip to another channel at
10 minutes in or 20 minutes in
and once an audience sits down in the
movie theater or they've paid their
eight bucks and pay-per-view on at their
home
they're in you got their money you got
their deal but in television they got to
watch those commercials all the way to
the last
you know seventh act and eighth act
so it's a very different scenario so
you know we look at them very
differently true they can and they can
pull their phone out in the movie
theater which they shouldn't be doing
but
but you still have their their ticket
sales yeah
yeah you don't lose them that way when
you executive produce a movie are you
putting in your own
funds well when you executive produce a
movie for a network and you're on the
hook for deficit
it's all your own funds so um if it's a
2.7 million movie and you've gotten
money from
lifetime and money from an international
distributor let's say sony
and you're shooting in winnipeg so you
have a
25 tax rebate all of that
doesn't get paid when you shoot it gets
paid
in draws along the way and the
biggest draw is usually on delivery so
you spend all of the money before you
deliver it
so you've got to go to a bank unless
you're independently wealthy which i'm
not
and borrow it so the tax credits are
borrowed against the network's
license fee or funding is borrowed
against the international distribution
fee is borrowed against
so in some ways it's all of your money
and then of course
if it's a 2.7 million movie and you end
up
spending 2.8 million a movie that's your
money there's nobody to go back to and
say i need more
the international receiver's not going
to give you more the network's not going
to give you more
and obviously the tax credit people are
not going to give you more so
um so you got to make sure you spend two
seven and maybe if you can spend 265 and
not affect the outcome of the movie and
put a little extra money in your pocket
but
generally yes it's all your money or the
bank's money
what is gaap insurance gaap insurance is
for
independent features where there's a gap
between how much money you've raised
and how much you need an insurance
company will cover
that on the idea that there's money
going to be coming in once it gets
released
in the future business you have upside
television movie business we don't get
to share in the advertising
so once i deliver a movie there's no
more profit for me
so i have to make it on the television
movie itself before i deliver
there's no net profits there's no gross
profits there's no
no there's no box office right so
there's no it's not even pay-per-view
there's nobody sending me a check after
i've delivered my television movie to
lifetime or hallmark or cbs nbc abc vox
in the feature business there's box
office there's pay-per-view there's
streaming there's all these sales that
can get made that can generate
more income so the gap
insurance is looking at all those
revenue streams and saying okay is this
a good bet if it's a good bad well
you pay for an insurance policy and
we'll give you the money and then we'll
recoup it from you
but you're going to get it from all
those other revenue streams
how do you talk to someone into giving
you money for a movie
uh you got to be a really good
storyteller i think pitching
has got to be your best skill if you're
asking somebody for money
because they're not investing in
the movie they're investing in you um
they're
counting on you to deliver that story
you just told them
but they're really counting on you
they're hoping that your experience
and your talent is what's going to get
it across the finish line and make them
money
so if i'm pitching a network they're
counting on me to deliver that movie
that i just pitched them
not to hand it off to someone and they
count on my experience and
my background to be what's going to get
them the movie that they want
and if it's an independent financer and
some some rich person that wants to
invest in a movie
then it's even more tenuous because they
don't have advertising that's going to
cover them
they don't know where their money's
going to come back from so it's it's
more risky so you better be a really
good storyteller
you better be confident passionate i
think passion is the
most important thing you can bring to a
pitch
you know my favorite quote about
hollywood is
from william goldman where he's the
thesis of his book adventures in the
screen trade is nobody knows anything
and the truth is we don't otherwise
every movie would be a hit and every
series would be
a 40 share but they're not and nobody
sets out to make a flop
so every time you go in you have the
highest of expectations and yet we don't
know what's going to happen we don't
know which ones are going to work and
not work
my friends you know marta kaufman and
david crane who i went to brandeis with
when they wrote friends they sure as
hell had no idea that's what they were
going to have
um and i have friends you know on the
other side of that coin
who do things that everybody says is
going to be hit and then
i remember when i worked at google
peters we had a movie with dennis quaid
who was a big star in martin short who
was an even bigger star
and it was the highest testing at that
moment it was produced by steven
spielberg and guber peters so they had
these two powerhouse producers
and at that moment in time it was the
highest rated
uh highest testing comedy in warner
brothers history and there was a movie
called inner space
and it was a massive flop and
nobody predicted that so that's the
truth nobody knows anything so if you're
not passionate about it
if you don't bring to that meeting where
you're asking somebody for money
incredible passion and desire and
enthusiasm
to try and get them to overcome those
fears that nobody knows anything
then the chances they're going to buy it
are pretty slim where i think about the
blair witch project
yeah this is endless
but i mean it especially if you didn't
found footage movie that it just
it didn't seem like it would be
something and paranormal activity
there you go yeah south park was a
christmas greeting card that got sent
around
and comedy central thought i mean you
really don't know nobody knows anything
nobody put the put those shows on and
went oh
that's going to be a hit or that's going
to be a flop
so from the passionate storytelling uh
point of view is that something you saw
with uh
peter cooper i mean did he yeah
both peter and john were two of the best
people at pitching i ever saw i learned
at the feet of the master but even
even my mentor tom tannenbaum who who
taught me the business before i met
peter and john was extraordinary at
pitching
um yeah i watched i learned it at the
feet of the masters
they were extraordinary and you know
when there was
three networks and those are the only
places you could go to sell something
you better be good at pitching because
there was no other place to go once they
said no
you heard three no's you were done now
you you know
you could be here until the cows come
home and still not have pitched every
network that can buy
so you know luxury now you can just keep
going and going and going with an idea
but when i started you had three places
to go
and if they said no you were done can
you pass on some knowledge
from what you've learned from your
mentors at the feet of the master's
issues uh
well peter was a very big believer in uh
getting looking
for an opportunity in every pitch to
make a connection to the person
peter was extraordinary at coming in
scanning the room
spotting a photo or a ward or
something and having a personal
connection to it so he could make a
personal connection to the
person buying and he would immediately
connect to them even if he never met
them
so by the time he we went in to start
the pitch there was a familiarity
between the two
oh our kids went to school together or
oh you're a
fan of the new york giants or oh you
grew up in
in brookline i grew up in newton you
know these are the things that he was
extraordinary at
he also could read a room and that's the
other thing people don't do well
anymore he was extraordinary at that
he could feel like he he believed and as
do i
and i teach in my class there's the lean
forward and lean back theory which is
if the person you're selling to leans
forward
they're interested they're hooked they
start to lean back you're losing them
and so don't keep pitching when they're
starting to lean back wrap it up or
go jump to something that's going to get
them to lean forward again but
read the room watch what's going on see
what they're reacting to
and if it's a pass remember what worked
in that pitch
and make sure that that's what you lean
on in the next pitch that the things
that didn't work you kind of
skirt around you're not gonna tell the
whole story you're not gonna tell every
character in a story
so you know it's like a comedian and
doing a set at the comedy store
don't repeat the jokes that don't work
and he was great at it but
but you know he had an enormous passion
for everything he sold
you believe that this was the only movie
he ever cared about all the other movies
he made he didn't care about but this
one
is the one he made you feel that and
i think you have to do that i try i
don't know if i'm certainly not as good
as peter is
but you know you have to make people
feel
that this is the most important movie
right that minute
what about when he felt something wasn't
right
like he should pass on it what were some
of the
the gut instincts that he would get when
i would pitch to him so that's that's
the other side of the coin
um he you had to
get him quick he had a very limited
attention span
so uh you better he better respond to it
fast so you better get out whatever it
is the hook the concept
it's where i learned the importance of
concept because i think concept is the
most important thing in a pitch
um concept first then characters then
plot plot being the least important
thing
and uh so i learned how to get you know
the sort of
essence of what i was pitching to him
out fast with a bit of a hook and some
like an action verb something that would
get him excited
right off the bat um i wouldn't wait
there's no
benefit in a slow start on a pitch
reeling them in quietly so that was
peter and i learned that from him
your focus has been in producing for the
last 30 years or so
now writing directing why this
transition and
what do you see for yourself going
forward i had been a
a very active prolific supplier of
television movies during the heyday of
the television movie sort of the back
end of the heyday so
i opened up my company in 1991
and we produced television movies until
about six years ago
when i started there was cbs nbc abc
then fox and then this whole
incredible number of networks i made the
first movie for mtv for tnt for abc
family for
espn even but now there's
pretty much if you want to own a movie
and do what i did in my career there's
pretty much a lifetime
and very little else everyone is now
working as an employee and sort of the
studio
model and so as i saw that coming on the
horizon
as it became clear that the the world
that i had
succeeded in and enjoyed so much as an
independent supplier
movie maker uh during the 90s and the
the o's the odds um was disappearing
and so i had a choice to continue down
that road and just
make less movies but i had really wanted
to
direct i had you know when he hit 60 65
films since television series
there's not a lot of mountains left to
climb um
i won an emmy i've been chairman of the
california film commission i had made
movies in
pretty much every quarter of the globe
uh
i lived out every dream i desperately
wanted to make a western on seriously
owned
sets in el maria i got to do that i
wanted to make a movie in australia new
zealand i got to do that i wanted to do
thrillers and westerns and romantic
comedies and a real comedy with a real
comedy genius and i got to do all those
things i worked with arnold
schwarzenegger on a movie that he
directed
so there weren't a lot of mountains left
to climb and i was still young
my kids were headed off to college and
so
i wanted more free time to myself i
wanted i didn't want to have a company
with
six or seven employees that were
counting on paychecks every week which
is a
you know pressure on itself and so about
five or six years ago i said
the only way this is going to happen for
me
is i have to step off the carousel so i
sold my development to one of my
friends and competitors in the tv movie
business and i took about six months to
decompress and then uh i started to
look for something i really wanted to
direct and i found a script that i had
developed myself
which was one of the only times i've
ever developed something at a network
and asked for it back
because it was really dark and they kept
making it lighter and lighter and
lighter and i said this is not a movie
really not a movie that is going to work
light it has to be as dark it means the
language it needs the sex it needs the
violence
it was definitely an indie feature that
we had sold as a television movie
so i picked that script up and i went
back to the screenwriters and said
turn this into an indie feature and they
did for free as a favor
and that was my first directing was sort
of my student film which was
perfect sisters which i made in winnipeg
and with a crew that i had
probably hired 10 times and i knew
really well and owed me
favors and also really wanted to work
hard for me um
and then i was blessed because for my
student film i ended up getting two
academy award
you know one academy award winner and
academy award nominee
and then georgie henley who had been in
um great movies and is now going to be
in the
game of thrones sequel so uh
i had a massive panic attack the night
before and
called three director friends to talk me
off with ledge and
went in and directed this little movie
and i loved every minute of it including
the
you know the horror of it which was you
know i remember that editor's cut when i
sobbed and
when i got rejected from a film festival
and and then the the
incredible joy of it finding an audience
and becoming one of the most successful
thrillers on netflix and getting renewed
and watching all the
reactions to it and the stuff online and
people creating fan fiction and
all the the reaction i don't get in a
television movie and i certainly don't
get as the director
and then from there i decided i wanted
to write and i
wrote two screenplays that i sold and
then um
i found that the the quiet solitude of
writing was something i loved and i
didn't expect that was a big surprise
that sitting alone in a room with a
blank laptop page
um was not as scary as i thought it
would be
um and i've adapted a couple of books
and i've done some originals and i'm
loving it and i'm about to start on my
second book and i just
it's a new chapter it's a very different
mindset
um i sort of likened producing in
television movies when i had my company
as the guy on
the sullivan with the pool cues and the
spinning plates and i would just run to
whatever one was wobbling i would be the
guy spinning it
to make sure that that one didn't fall
but you'd have to have 20
spinning plates and cues pool cues to
have a business
and you had to have employees and so to
to what i do now is much more project
oriented so
i enjoy just living with certain
characters
for long periods of time but getting up
in the morning and going back to them
with having them
stand on the edge of the the forest and
wait for me and oh look
stands back and i get to play with them
again when i did julie hann's
script a girl who fell from the sky i i
read a lot about what semeka's
process was on castaway and i read a lot
about the process
um they went through 127 hours and i
thought okay what's it going to be like
to write a movie for
a single lead for a big chunk of my
script where there's nobody for them to
talk
to how do i do that how do i approach
that and i
i i remember hitchcock wrote in his
autobiography that the part of the
creative process he loved was painting
himself into a corner and finding a way
out
he made a lifeboat because someone said
there was no way you could make a
scary thriller if you could see
everything from every direction and no
one could move
and so he said okay well let's try that
let's see if that could happen and
he made rope to see if he could make a
movie that was all one shot
and a continuous take i like that
challenge it's a very different
challenge a very different headspace
than being a producer
i like the creative box that i have to
find my way
into and out of and i mean really
enjoying it as for as long as i'm
enjoying it
and able to get people to make my movies
or
television series or let me direct an
episode i mean i will say directing an
episode of agents of shield
was the most fun i've ever had in the
business
it's a very different experience than
when you're the boss
you're like a very very very expensive
subsidy teacher and you come into the
classroom and everybody knows each other
and
they can finish each other's sentences
and they can tell all the same jokes and
you can't
and yet you're still the boss and you
still have to decide where the camera's
going and
you know where to cut and so it's it's a
really you know and
they have so much more money to spend so
coming from the television movie indie
feature business where
you know we'd have very little time and
no money uh it was amazing to me when i
could have any crane
any lens and all the things all the toys
i never got to play with i got to play
with on agents of shield
and that was just a totally new after
all these years in the business i had a
new experience
and i guess the thing i needed the most
which is why i left producing on a big
scale
and decided to write and direct was fear
i wanted to be scared again there was
nothing in the television movie business
as a producer
that was daunting because i had done it
all there was no challenge
i remember we were shooting um patricia
cornwell's move book
for a lifetime and uh we had a the
third lead had not been cast on a friday
and we went to camera on monday
and we were in toronto and we were
casting this part out of los angeles
and uh i was in my office talking to the
network and talking to the casting
director and i had my feet up and
i had an iced tea in my hand and the
production
coordinator and the upm and the line
producer all walked in my office to
close the door and said
why are you not freaking the hell out
and i said because come monday morning
there will be an actress in wardrobe in
hair and makeup
saying the lines how do you know that
because i've done this
so many times and sure enough on
saturday
we found a wonderful actress and
ashley williams got on a plane on sunday
and was in makeup and hair and did an
amazing job because that's how it works
if you've done this enough you know
how things are going to work out and i
wanted to be
scared again i wanted that panic attack
that i had the night before i directed
my first
day of first year time i yelled action i
wanted
i still have it when i go to pitch a
feature which i had never done before
i go to talk independent finding these
are scary moments for me
and it's nice to be scared again i
hadn't felt that in a long time